ANANTH SUNDARRAJAN: Thank
you for coming here.
Migrating on to Google
Cloud Platform is a journey.
And with any great journey,
it starts with a single step.
Now if you're here,
if you're sitting here
planning to think
about that first step,
or if you're running a
marathon on the GCP world,
I hope Unity's
experience over here
would give you some of the
insights on what's to come.
Although I will touch upon
the overall migration of Unity
on the GCP, but the
focus of our talk today
is on the networking piece
of the whole migration.
But before I jump in, I do
want to take this opportunity
to introduce ourselves.
Ariel, who is the lead
networking architect at Unity,
she's been closely in while
not just with the migration
of networking on to GCP but also
running the workloads on GCP
ever since we migrated.
Her perspective as
a customer of GCP
is very valuable,
because she brings
a very different perspective,
which is your perspective,
to the whole story.
Thank you Ariel for being
here and sharing your stories
with us.
It takes two hands to clap.
I have Davis here
who is our networking
engineer from Google.
He's been the backbone of the
migration from the Google side.
And today he's going to bring
the Google's point of view
to the whole
migration and probably
share some inside
scoops on the migration.
I am the technical account
manager for Unity from Google.
Along with my team of
engineers and consultants,
I am responsible to
make sure that Unity
is successful on GCP.
In short, the voice of Google
in Unity and the voice of Unity
at Google.
If you have any questions
during this session,
we're using Dory Q&A. Please
do go on to your Next app,
click on the session.
You will find a
link for Dory Q&A.
Please do write your
questions in there
and you can upvote
questions that you think you
want to be answered over here.
If you're not able to
answer any questions,
we'll definitely get back on
the Dory Q&A with the answers.
All right.
Before we dive into
any of the details
over here, for those of
you who don't know what
or who Unity
Technologies is, Unity
is a big name in
the gaming industry.
Among other things that
Unity is known for,
it's known for its
Unity gaming engine,
which is a platform that helps
game developers build games.
"Assassin's Creed,"
"Pokemon Go" are
some of the many, many games
that have been built on Unity
itself.
They've had more than
29 billion installs--
are 29 billion installs of Unity
experience in the last year.
If you think about it, it's
about 3.5 times the population
of the world.
They are a key player in the
AR, VR, and the mobile games
industry.
At Google, our vision is to
create, connect, and scale
games.
We've had the greatest of
our Google products invested
in this vision.
And together we're
trying to make
sure the gaming part at
Google is successful.
With the addition of
Stadia into our arsenal,
I'm very excited to see how
the space turns in the future.
Now what happens when you
bring two big names together?
Magic.
Google and Unity have been
partnering on multiple fronts
to make gaming experience
more rich and more inclusive
for everyone.
We have a bunch of
sessions during Next
to talk about various
initiatives that
have come out of this such as
connected games, matchmaker.
I would highly encourage you
to attend those sessions.
But before all this
magic actually happens,
Unity had to get onto the
Google Cloud Platform.
And that's where the
journey actually started.
With the scale of Unity,
we had to do this quick
and we had to get this right.
Unity had offices
across the globe.
And we had to make
sure that each
of these offices, the
workloads running out of them,
had to be migrated onto
Google Cloud Platform.
My team was entrusted
with the task
to make sure that this
migration is successful.
The PSO or the professional
service organization
is a team of technical
account managers, engineers,
and consultants that
work on ensuring
that customers such as Unity can
accelerate as soon as possible
on the Google Cloud Platform.
We are spread globally and
quite effectively that way.
Long story short, in
a span of six months,
we were able to
successfully migrate Unity
onto the Google Cloud platform.
Now we're not going to get
into the nitty gritties
of the migration.
If you are interested,
again there's
another session
tomorrow that talks
about this in quite detail.
Ah.
There you go.
So here we are
after the migration.
Unity has been using a whole
host of Google Cloud products
right from compute all
the way to Cloud AI.
But the focus of today's
talk we're going to deep dive
into the networking
components that we have.
Along with Davis and Ariel,
we're going to talk about some
of the experiences, challenges,
decisions, and hacks
both on the Unity
and the Google side
that we made on making sure all
these products were onboarded
and are successfully
running at the moment.
We're going to take a quick
peek into the networking
world of Unity.
We're going to share our
experiences on the migration
phase itself and
the processes that
are put in place
for post migration
to ensure that Unity's
networking workloads are set up
for success on GCP.
Ariel, once again, thanks
for sharing your experiences
on this.
ARIEL WEI: Of course.
And my pleasure.
And I hope sharing our
experiences here can be
helpful to the audience here.
All right, thanks.
So before we dive into the
network architecture of Unity
and GCP, I want to run
through some characteristics
and requirements of
our infrastructure.
So we have a hybrid
infrastructure.
So we have some small
footprint in data center
physical location and most
of our workload running
in public cloud.
And our infrastructure
is not only
span across multiple region.
It's also span across
multiple clouds.
Fiber backbone is
primarily IPsec based.
But for some workload
between certain environments
we do have the requirement
to have much higher capacity
bandwidth requirement where
multiple IPsec panels are not
going to meet the requirement.
And also our infrastructure
have very high growth rate.
So our design in GCP
need to be able to scale.
So with that in mind, when
we start our journey in GCP,
start to build in 2018, we
work with the Google team
and quickly come up with a set
of key architecture decisions.
Those decisions then later
on play the key factor in
to determine the final
GCP network build.
So first, we work
with the Google team.
We decided to use one
VPC for transiting
routing between GCP and the
other cloud infrastructure
we have.
And also we know
that, especially
during the migration, we will
need some partner interconnect
based product to link
between the environment,
certain environments, to
provide much higher bandwidth.
And also we decided
to use global routing
versus regional routing.
The reason being is because
with the global routing
we will be able to do
failover between regions,
hence increase our
network availability.
Also we decided to
use Cloud Routers.
So our team do
have the experience
to use over the shelf virtual
routing and encryption
equipment.
And also we have the experience
of manage and maintain
Linux-based open source routing
and encryption processes.
However, we choose
to use Cloud Router
because it's purely
API driven and it makes
our automation super easy.
And also we decided
to put some workload
into shared VPC architecture.
The reason to use
shared VPC architecture
is because use the architecture
it allows us to aggregate all
our workload into a
fewer VPC, hence reduce
the ongoing operational cost.
So equipped with those key
decisions, we dive into the PLC
pretty quickly.
And there are many
lessons learned.
And there's something
specifically related
with the routing I want to
share with the audience here.
So the first snag we hit when
we tried to do transit VPC
is the interoperability
between CSRs in AWS
and the cloud routers in GCP.
So the CSRs in AWS are
behind the net IP address.
So by default, we were
trying to negotiate--
do that IKE negotiation, it
will use the VM's private IP
as the local identity.
And that caused the cloud--
not cloud router--
the VPN in Google site
to reject IKE negotiation.
So the fix is fairly simple.
The fix is to have
one line of command
in Cisco CSR and
the IKE where you
can specify to use the public
net IP of the Cisco CSR
as the local identity
for IKE negotiation.
So with that, we continued to
look into the routing aspect
of the transit VPC.
For routing, we
used Cloud Router.
Cloud router for me is like the
VTW in AWS world in the sense
that it provided functionality
to allow dynamic routing change
using BGP as well as
you have the ability
to propagate the route--
to program the route
into the VPC or subnet.
However, there is one key
behavior difference there.
So if Cloud Router,
they don't really
automatically redistribute
the best route, the BGP route,
between the BGP peers.
And also we notice that as
we learn more about GCP,
we realized we need to
do route summarization.
Reason being is there
are certain limits
you need to be aware of.
There is a limit about
how many prefixes you can
announce through a BGP peer.
And there is a limit on how
many unique prefixes you
can program into a VPC in GCP.
So to do route summarization,
we choose to use custom routes.
And you can do custom routes
on the per cloud router level
or per VPN level--
the BGP peer level.
And also while we
start to experiment
and doing PLC about
this transit VPC idea,
we learned that there
is a need for two
set of cloud routers in each
region for transitive routing.
To give more color on that, so
this is a simplified diagram
of the initial POC
where we will have
one's cloud routers in
the middle portion, which
is a transit VPC.
That is cloud router
have a BGP relationship
with the CSRs in AWS.
And also it have
BGP relationship
with the environment
of one VPC, which
we call it downstream VPC.
And that Cloud Router
intransitive VPC
will learn a prefix one
from AWS from the CSR.
And we use custom
routes and hope
that the customer routes
will then be re-advertised
into environment one VPC.
But that's not the case.
So in the end, we have
to use two cloud routers.
So in the transit VPC,
we have cloud router one
and cloud router two.
Cloud router one is used
to receive the prefix
from the CSR.
And then the cloud
Router will then program the
route into the transit VPC
routing table.
And cloud router two--
and cloud router two will
then use custom route
to announce the prefix one into
the environment one VPC Cloud
Router.
By doing routing
this way, we'll all
be able to do transit routing
between AWS and the environment
in one VPC.
So now here is the diagram shows
other routing with more detail.
So the middle section
is the transit VPC.
And in the transit VPC,
we have cloud routers
in different regions.
In each region, we have a
set of cloud routers for one
plus one redundancy for
connectivity and exchange
routes with the CSRs in AWS.
And also we have a set
of transit cloud routers
for route exchange with the
environment with VPC cloud
routers there.
And also within the transit
VPC, we use global routing.
With global routing enabled,
each of the global route--
the cloud router will
have a global route
view of the whole VPC.
What it means that if, for
example, we have the BGP or BGP
fail within region one, and the
workload in the environment one
VPC will still be able to
reroute it through the nearest
region to reach AWS.
And also here I want you
all to see the bowtie style
of connectivity.
I want to stress that it
only represents the control
path for routing selection.
So for actual data paths, it
goes through the VPN gateway.
So for VPN gateway, we can
scale horizontally as we need.
Sorry.
And now let's look into
how we do networking
inside environment VPC.
So we use share VPC.
In this diagram on the top,
you will see a share VPC
in a hosted project.
In that shared VPC, you will
see that we have cloud routers
in many different regions.
And then from that cloud
router, we have connectivity
to the upstream transit VPC.
And also in the
shared VPC, we create
a subnet in different
region and then
we share the permission
to use the subnet
with the maintainer of different
resources in the service
projects.
So for our
development team, they
know if they get a subnet
from us from the shared VPC,
if access control
permits, they will
be able to reach to the
outer workload regardless
of which region
that workload is in
and which infrastructure
that workload is in.
So this is how we do
networking in Unity in GCP.
But there are many
other options that you
can use to connect
different VPCs
and infrastructure together.
So next, Davis, do you want
to go through those options?
DAVIS PYNADATH: Absolutely.
Thanks Ariel for walking
us through Unity's network
architecture as well
as highlighting a few
of the caveats you mentioned.
Now at this point, I want
us to take a step back,
because I want to highlight
what are the different design
options for interconnecting
VPCs in Google Cloud.
So Unity leveraged VPNs.
But based on a use case, you
could leverage different design
options.
For each option, I'm going
to highlight the advantages
and constrictions,
And hopefully this
should help you make
the right decision
as to how to interconnect VPCs.
So when you leverage VPNs, the
major advantages that it gives
is it enables transitive
topologies if you are
using static cloud based VPNs.
And if you need dynamic
cloud based VPNs,
you will have to use two cloud
routers as mentioned earlier
by Ariel.
Secondly, you can scale
the number of VPN tunnels
if you need higher bandwidth.
And also the choice
of the tunnel
is based on a phi double hash.
It is a managed service and
has an SLA of three lines.
Now what are the
constrictions with VPNs?
Each VPN tunnel has about 1.5
gigs over public internet.
So you can, of course, scale
with adding more tunnels.
And also you need to account
for the IPsec headers.
Right.
So on the remote end on
your on prem router maybe,
you have to configure [? 14 ?]
60 bytes for your ethernet MTU.
This results in a decrease
in the maximum segment size
and hence less good [INAUDIBLE].
Something to be aware of.
And finally, I'm sure at
least few you in the audience
if you have ever
created an IPsec
tunnel would have troubleshooted
IKE phase 1, phase 2
negotiation.
So there is a little bit
of overhead and management
constraints.
So the next approach
for interconnecting VPCs
is by leveraging a
multi-NIC VM where
each network interface goes to
a distinct VPC in the project.
So this is typical as
illustrated in this diagram.
So this is a design
option that you
would leverage when you
need all your traffic to go
to an appliance like a next
generation firewall that
does deep packet inspection.
Now with this approach, what
are the major advantages?
So each core of a CPU of the
VM has a peak performance
of two gigs.
And if you leverage eight
cores, you get 16 gigs.
But adding more than 8 won't
give you higher throughput.
but this is again
going to change.
You can also scale to manage
instance group and ECMP grants.
The major
[? constrations ?] involved
that each VPN can have a maximum
of eight NICs, meaning you
can interconnect
maximum eight VPCs.
All these VPCs must belong
in the same project.
And today load balancing
is only supported on nic0.
And for non-nic0, you would have
to leverage GCP static routes
and ECMP across them.
That is by having
multiple static outs
with equal priority.
The final approach for
interconnecting VPCs
is by leveraging VPC
peering where you peer
to VPCs using Google's STMP.
So these VPCs can be
in different projects
in the same organization
or it could be
across different organization.
So here is VPC A peering
with VPC B in the diagram.
So the major advantages is
it's very high bandwidth.
Right.
It's as if all the VPCs in the
peering group is a single VPC.
It's very easy configuration.
All you need to state is
the project ID as well as
the remote VPC you
want to peer with.
And that's pretty much it.
And you have general
control as to the number
of-- as to the custom routes,
the dynamic and static routes,
you want to import and export.
And what are the
major constrictions.
So it is non-transitive.
So if you take--
if VPC A pairs with B and C, B
and C cannot communicate with
each other.
They have to be
directly connected.
Also something to
be aware of when
you operate at very large scale
is that certain resource quotes
are aggregated across all the
VPCs in the peering group.
Just to name a few is the VM
count and internal forwarding
nodes.
So I hope highlighting the
advantages and constrictions
will help you make
better decision
choices with your
network design in GCP.
Now coming back to
Unity's network journey,
certain key efforts
were taken by the teams
to onboard internal customers
into a completely new platform.
Also, tooling was developed
by the infra team at Unity
in order to easily enable
customers to use a shared VPC.
And I'll have Ariel
to speak more on this.
ARIEL WEI: All right.
So after we built the network,
we spent a lot of effort
to onboard our
internal customers.
And it's a big effort.
And it's effort actually across
many different teams, not just
us.
So first we ran a
lot of onboarding
related presentations.
We have the presentation
with different customers
in different regions.
And in the
presentation, we focused
on describing to
the customer what's
the new architecture
in GCP, what's
the characteristics
of our network,
such as what's the
bandwidth that's
supported, what they can
expect in terms of bandwidth
between different environments,
what's the latency,
and what's the service level
objectives that we use to come
up with the network design.
And those informations are very
important for our development
teams to be able to eventually
come up with their migration
strategy that can be
supported by the underlying
infrastructure.
We also created a
GCP kickstart guide.
It's a guide that provided
step by step instructions
on how to start in GCP, such
as how to create a project, how
to access to the
project, how to be
able to share the permissions
with the other team members.
And we also created a
portal for project creation.
It's not as simple as
just to create a project.
It's actually a
suite of actions.
It will create a project.
And if the project requires
to use the shared VPC,
it will then be attached
to our host project.
And also it will delete things
like the default network
and create relevant
service accounts.
And we also create a portal
for firewall rule request.
It's a GUI driven portal.
And turns out we didn't
have the very high adoption
rate as we hoped, because
most of our developers
like to write infrastructure
in code although it
proved to be very useful to
some teams and some people.
And then we decided to
share our Terraform repos
on subnets and firewall rules
with the development team.
And to do that, we used
Terraform modules whenever
that makes sense to enforce a
certain standard and templates.
And also we found it's really
useful to install some linters.
The linters we installed in
our platform CD pipeline,
it allows us to be able
to verify and qualify
a merger request
before a human come
to review the merger request.
What it does is,
for example, it will
check if the format is right,
if there is any syntax errors,
or if there are any variables
used that are not declared.
Also, it will check, for
example, for firewall rules.
It will check if
the firewall rule
name is more than 63 character,
which typically you will only
notice that at the time
of the terraform apply
and it will be able
to expose to you
because Google API
will give you an error.
But with that linter, we can
detect those errors upfront.
And using these
methods and tactics
that it help us to
onboard our customers
span across different
locations without us
being the bottleneck.
As we onboard
customer, we also start
to work on the network
monitoring and logging
because we want to
make sure we have
the visibility of
our network health
within GCP as our
internal customers start
to iterate within GCP.
So we have our own in-house
monitoring implementation.
With the help from our
monitoring and logging team,
we quickly implemented
some backbone connectivity
monitoring.
It will monitor the
connectivity and the latency
and availability between
different environments
within GCP and outside GCP.
We also use our
in-house monitoring
for metric gathering of some
VMs running network services,
such as network
address translation.
And we also heavily utilize
a Stackdriver logging
and monitoring,
especially for elements
such as the Google VPN gateway
or Google Cloud routers.
So speak of Stackdriver.
Davis, do you want to give
us some examples on how
to mine the Cloud Router events
using Stackdriver logging?
DAVIS PYNADATH: Absolutely.
Yeah.
Thanks, Ariel.
So I want to walk through a few
examples of using Stackdriver
logging queries to data
mine cloud routing events.
Right.
So the first one is
when a cloud router
is being upgraded or migrated.
So this is usually,
since cloud router
is a fully managed
service, it does
undergo upgrades and patches.
Right.
And these upgrades are completed
in less than 60 seconds.
The hold down timer
is 60 seconds,
meaning traffic
forwarding should not
be affected as the
routes are preserved.
So what you need to
look out for is--
not sure if it's clear.
So essentially you
go to Cloud Console.
And then you hit logging,
Stackdriver logging, logs,
and you convert into
an advance filter
where you search for
resource type GC router
and look for the
keyword task activated.
So this is something
that you should track.
This is an event that
you should track.
Next is something, an event of
when a BGP peering goes down.
So this is essentially
a network outage
if you don't have
redundancy in place.
So a critical event
to look out for.
What happens is you need to look
for the keywords BGP peering
and went down.
And as you can see
here, the neighbor 1.6
has gone down at that
particular timestamp.
And immediately after
the neighbor goes down,
well, they're also going to
be evicted from the VPC table.
And what you look
for in this case
is the Route Event and
deleted from the cloud router.
So as you can see here,
10.2.0.0/24 is being evicted
from the same router whose
peering session went down
earlier from the earlier slide.
So this is, essentially,
I just wanted
to give you a glimpse of how
you could use Stackdriver log
inquiries.
Now, what do you do with these?
So you could export it into
Pub/Sub and a Pub/Sub topic.
And as these events
occur, you could
trigger a Cloud
Function that executes
an API for [INAUDIBLE].
So that is kind of the
capability of Stackdriver.
And, well, I now
want to kind of focus
on a particular
network service, which
is Network Address Translation.
The reason I bring this
up is because there
are a few considerations
with its implementation.
And I believe it will be useful
to you to be aware of it.
So, firstly, there
are two approaches
to implementing NAT in GCP.
The first one is
self-managed NAT
where you run a VM
with NAT software
or maybe a Linux VM doing IP
tables for NAT functionality.
So what are the considerations
with this approach?
You need to monitor the VM
for scale as well as for load.
You need to create certain
scripts to do this.
Second, I cannot
stress enough on this,
it breaks Google Private Access.
So, now, what is Private Access?
It's basically private
VMs having the capability
to make GCP API
calls and services
through Google's backbone.
This is made possible
using a default route
with the next stop as
default internet gateway.
So when you override that route,
and when you create a default
route with next stop
as NAT instance,
all your traffic is going
to go through NAT instance,
and it overloads the NAT,
and it might bring down
the NAT instance.
So I've been on many
troubleshooting calls
essentially fixing this.
So yeah, it's an
important caveat to note.
Next is the same point
I mentioned earlier
with multi-NIC VMs.
Each vCPU has about 2
gigs peak performance.
And as you use [INAUDIBLE]
you get 16 gigs
as max for peak performance.
Now, what is Cloud NAT?
And how does this help at all?
Well, it is
Google-managed service.
It has an SLA of [INAUDIBLE].
It is highly available,
as well as [INAUDIBLE],,
without any user
intervention or management.
The perks of running
a managed service.
Now, Private Google Access
automatically works,
and your bandwidth is
as of your private VMS
that need to be NATed
having an external IP.
So, essentially, huge
performance benefits.
Considerations, though.
Cloud NAT does not support
application-level gateways.
What this means is certain
protocols, like SIP and FTP,
they require the IP
in the application
PDU to be NATed also.
So Cloud NAT does not have
that functionality today.
Logging is in Alpha.
And also, finally, when
you create Cloud NAT,
you have to specify the
maximum number of ports
which are available to each VM.
By default, it's 64 ports.
So if you say 64 ports
are available to each VM
for [? NATing ?] purposes,
and the VM essentially
makes a large number
of connections
to the same destination IP
and port, which is always 64,
then the packet is
not going to be NATed.
So you need to kind
of plan what subnets
or what workstreams need to be
made available for Cloud NAT.
And I think Ariel will
share her experience
on its implementation at Unity.
ARIEL WEI: So for the
Unity NAT implementation.
When we first started
back in early 2018,
our choice is very
simple, because there
is no Cloud NAT available.
So we created many NAT clusters.
We have one NAT cluster in each
region and each environment.
And also, we use route
tags to route route tags,
and then provide those tags
to our development team.
So the development team
can use these tags once.
It's applied to a VM.
It will route the
internet traffic.
When I say internet, the
traffic goes to prefix of 000/0,
what we route is through
the relevant NAT cluster.
So it works well at
the very beginning.
However, later in
the migration, we
start to notice that,
occasionally, our NAT
clusters may get overwhelmed.
And this is a usage graph.
And it shows, you can see,
that the traffic pattern
can be really spiky.
And this is only a throughput
for one environment and one
region we have.
And at times, we
will see traffic
goes from
4-point-something gigabit
per second to 40-plus gigabit
per second within five minutes.
And when we look deeper, we
notice majority of this traffic
are actually not the traffic
go to the public internet.
A lot of the traffic is
actually goes to the Google API
services, like GCS or GCR.
And then, luckily,
at the time when
we start to
experience this issue,
Cloud NAT is
already [INAUDIBLE]..
But before we immediately
jump into the Cloud NAT
implementation, we looked at
several different options.
We look at option
where we can possibly
inject more specific
routes in the routing table
for certain Google APIs
to route those traffic
through the Google
internet gateway that
allows Private Google Access.
We also looked at these
restricted Google API access
feature, but we
have some concerns
about how to do the
DNS using that feature.
And eventually,
after some analysis,
we decided Google Cloud NAT
is the direction we should go.
So when we start looking
to migrate workloads
into Cloud NAT, the first
question we ask ourselves,
what are the workload we
should be focusing on in
migrating to Cloud NAT?
At the time, our NAT clusters
occasionally get overwhelmed.
We want to be able to
stabilize our service.
So in order to find the
top talker, what we did
is to utilize the flow logs.
So we enabled flow logs
for the subnet, where
our NAT devices uses, and
then we send those flow logs
into BigQuery, and with
a fairly simple query,
we will be able to
find the top talkers.
So identify the top talkers
allows us to figure out
which development team we
then should collaborate with
to migrate those
traffic into Cloud NAT.
And then the second
question we ask
ourselves is how to
qualify if a workload is
a good candidate for Cloud NAT?
Because of the caveats that
Davis mentioned before,
when you create a
Cloud NAT, you do
have to actually put a number
for a maximum concurrent
connection a VM can
establish to a destination
IP and a port combination.
So what we don't want is
to migrate something, jump
into Cloud NAT,
migrate to Cloud NAT,
and potentially have workload
experience [INAUDIBLE] failures
because of the port exhaustion.
So what we did is to
first mine the flow
logs we have in the query.
But for some reason, we
find that we can't really
find all the flows that for
one particular stream before it
goes into the NAT, after
it come out of the NAT,
get NATed, and come back, and
eventually back to the VM.
And maybe that's
because of the sampling.
We didn't look further.
But we quickly developed
another method.
So our team members
start to take snapshot
of all the connection tracking
tables across all the NAT
devices within one cluster.
And then we have a
little simple Go client.
That Go client basically
inject all these connection
tracking table, information
and parse it, and then send it,
stream it into BigQuery.
With this method, we basically
gain the real-time visibility
into the characteristics
of all our traffic
that outbound to the internet.
And this allows us
to be able to tell,
by looking to a subnet, normally
correlates to one workload,
it will tell us how many
concurrent connections,
the maximum concurrent
connections, from the time
we enable the method that
can ever recorded if that
can be supported by Cloud NAT.
So after we find the
top talkers and qualify
if they're a good
candidate to Cloud NAT,
then we ask ourselves
the third question.
How to migrate from using our
NAT devices into Cloud NAT
with minimum service impact?
So we choose to enable Cloud
NAT on a per subnet basis.
And also, once we
enable the Cloud NAT
for that particular subnet, then
it's up to our development team
to remove the NAT
tag at their pace
whenever they're ready to
migrate into Cloud NAT.
Once they remove
the NAT tag, what's
the impact to the
existing traffic?
For the existing
connections, when
you switch from NAT to the
Cloud NAT, it will send a reset.
So for the type of workload
we have, the traffic we have,
it's nearly not detectable
for this transition.
So it turns out that
to migrate to Cloud NAT
is actually fairly manageable.
But we're still
trying to figure out,
how can we do capacity planning
and ongoing capacity planning,
so that we can take a
more proactive position?
And that is true
not only for NAT,
but also that's true for
all the other services we
manage in GCP.
So now after one year in
GCP, what should we do?
What should we be focusing on?
Of course, we pop a
bottle of champagne first.
And then after that,
we know that we
need to monitor quota
and the resource usage,
the reason being is that
once we situated into GCP,
the workload continue to grow.
So we have to keep our eye and
have a good visibility into all
the quota usage
and resource usage,
so that we can be
more proactive.
And also, we need to focus
on optimizing our workload,
not only just for
cost optimization,
but also for service
performance optimization.
And then we start to
have more and more ask
from different
development teams where
they have their own self-managed
infrastructure where
they want to be able to
connect into GCP directly.
And for example, now we
are working on a project
where we will utilize
the new Hong Kong
region offered by
GCP for connectivity
and better connectivity
into our infrastructure
in mainland China.
And also, we invest very
heavily on automation.
We invest on automation
for the purpose
to have a self-service
approach for our developers,
so that they can iterate
really fast rather than create
a request and wait for
us to do the request.
And also, for the purpose
of reduced operational cost.
And also, speak
from the experience.
I think public cloud
technology evolved very fast.
And also, Google release new
features on a regular basis.
So it's always
something that we need
to keep informed on the new
features and new product,
and reevaluate our architecture
to ensure that we can
meet the future growth needs.
So this is our network team's
focus after the migration.
And, Davis, you interact
with many other customers.
Do you want to add
anything else here?
DAVIS PYNADATH: Yes, absolutely.
Thanks, Ariel.
So, one, as Ariel
mentioned earlier,
carefully monitor your quotas.
So these quotas are present
to prevent abuse of a platform
as well as to protect you
from unforeseen usages.
So there are two kinds
of quotas, rate quotas,
which get reset maybe every day,
maybe every minute, depending
on the API you're calling.
There's also the
resource quotas,
which is essentially like a
VM [INAUDIBLE] project, which
doesn't get reset.
So you need to carefully
monitor and proactively request
for quota increases, because
depending on your resource,
it does take time for approval.
Second, so we are at Next.
There are a lot of product
announcements happening
this week to test it out and
provide feedback, so that we
can quickly iterate over it.
Also, for the existing
products today, there
is a platform in which
you can essentially
file issues and
feature requests,
so that if you feel certain
products should behave
differently or does not have a
supported functionality, well,
you can use this.
So this is kind of
how it looks like.
It's a public page,
and you just needed
it to mine the component.
And if there's already an
issue that you want to file,
and if it already
exists, [INAUDIBLE]
so that more eyes
are looking at it.
Finally, for your favorite
GCP products, bookmark it.
Example is, well, here is
Cloud NAT maturing from beta
[INAUDIBLE] last year.
And finally, we
continuously strive
to expand our regions globally.
And, well, as you
mentioned, we do
have a region in Hong
Kong, which is asia-east2.
So if you have queries
on accessibility of users
to GCP resources,
like accessibility
of users in China
to GCP resources,
well, there are
interconnectivity options.
We have the China specialist
team sitting in this room
right here or you can come
talk to me later about it, too.
ANANTH SUNDARRAJAN: All right.
Thanks, Davis.
So I hope this
experience sharing
that we had between
Google and Unity
has helped you out to
think beyond the obvious.
And we do hope that while you
are planning your migration,
you do keep these
points in mind.
If you're already
in [INAUDIBLE] you
could probably reevaluate it and
see if that's the right thing
to do or if there
any other things
that you can add to what the
current architecture that you
have.
If you do need some help in
getting your pipes in order,
please give us a shout-out.
We'll more than happy to
let you know our experiences
or we can definitely connect you
to teams who can help you out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]